hi fabi thanks for joining uh
this interview with chess.com
where we're going to focus on uh
on the match the upcoming match between
magnus and jan but of course
we're also going to talk about your uh
your match with magnus from three years
ago
uh you are the closest person uh to uh
to for anyone to describe what it's like
of course to playing uh much like that
i'll um
i'll first ask you some general
questions then maybe a few a few
more bit specific ones to uh
to the one you played in london with
magnus
and then going back uh zooming out a
little bit again
and and yeah maybe looking forward to
to the new world championship that will
be played this year
so i wanted to start actually where it
kind of started for you and that is uh
you uh won the candidates tournament
and
i was just wondering when
can you set
the scene from there uh
like what is it like for example you you
win
you wake up the next morning and there
must be a moment where you're like okay
i'm gonna i'm gonna play world
championship match how does that feel
yeah well the the candidates really
starts months before
the actual games begin yeah um
there is a long qualification process
which is
extremely difficult and i don't think
anyone
uh is exempt from from the difficulty
everyone has to struggle to qualify
and there's also a great deal of
preparation that comes in after you've
qualified
um
it's it's not quite at the level of a
world championship match but it's it's
almost there in terms of the level of
preparation the level of tension
uh the amount at stake is it's pretty
much the the
the only thing that can be almost
compared to a world championship match
and and there's this intense period of
months and months and of course during
the tournament it's it's even more
intense it's um about three weeks
that you play and even on rest days
you're still filled with the tension of
uh
what's going to happen for the next game
what am i going to prepare what am i
going to do
uh and
so once it's over the immediate thing is
just
i guess some sort of
release of stress and and not not much
thought immediately
at least for me i can only speak from my
personal experience
um is given to the match of course that
comes later and then there's a huge
amount of work and preparation that goes
into the match but
but the morning after or let's say a few
days after uh
not much i wasn't really thinking about
the match
especially because i also had a
tournament that was
uh that i played
like two days later after the candidates
finished
all right the grand gay tournament
that's crazy
yeah and you didn't you win that one as
well yeah yeah that was a good period
for me i i right i carried over with
like i guess the euphoria
um or the momentum that i have from the
candidates and i play very well there
um but yeah then of course you start to
think um
yeah i'm playing a world championship
match but it only really
hit me
maybe like a week before we were parried
maybe 10 days a week before that this is
actually happening um
and i'm going to go to london and this
is the end of the preparation because we
had all this it felt like an abundance
of time to think about
the approach and the openings
and magnus and uh and the entirety of
the match
and then a week before you realize that
even with all the time you didn't do as
much as you wanted to do
um
but you're saying before we get to that
preparation you're saying that like a
week or ten days before that was only
that it was actually your personal
realization that
you're actually going to be part of a
match and and
[Music]
is actually happening
well yeah let's say the the emotional
realization like the feeling
of it i think i felt it also i was
playing the olympia before our last
training session before the match
and i think i did feel it there because
i was very
kind of on edge during that tournament i
felt stressed out
um so i think it was already starting to
hit me but then
yeah about
yeah about 10 days before it was during
um let's say a final training session
before we went to london
and
and that was when um yeah i kind of
emotionally it started to impact me
uh and you know the first game is when
like it gets i guess more real
and more real until you're actually
sitting
down at the board for the first game
yeah yeah yeah and then
uh
now that we're at this
you you actually
there is a moment where you actually
enter the playing hall you sit behind
the chessboard and then
of course there's unlike any other
tournament there's like 30 photographers
clicking away
and that must be
the moment then that you realize how big
this is
well it was uh the moment i realized how
how stressful it it was and would be um
because it that was a
yeah i think that this
that puts it pretty well that was a very
that was an indescribable moment for me
because i sat down we were in a pretty
much a
glass box
where we couldn't really see outside by
there was a number of spectators
uh watching us
and there were yeah maybe 20 or 30
photographers
uh crowded around the board um
and yeah that that's i think the moment
when the stress really first hit me and
of course it doesn't really leave for
the entirety of the match
but you get more used to it
um
i think it was lucky for me that i
survived that first game
um
because
i i was dead lost
um it really wasn't i was pretty much in
the worst possible position i was in
unfamiliar situation and
i was outplayed early on by magnus
uh i'll prepare certainly and uh
i got a losing position with almost no
time in the clocks and somehow i
survived that and then they gave me um
some push for
um
let's say some
kind of
more of an internal belief
um that this was a match that i could
win
uh while i've lost that first game it
might have been
might have been a really really
difficult situation
this is actually good i think for you
describe i mean we all know you there's
months of preparation you have your your
tournaments that are scheduled of course
uh
most of them you you still play uh maybe
uh later on you might have to withdraw
for for uh one or two events but
it comes down to that as you said you
have heaps of time months of preparation
uh can you describe a little bit on on
how that works you get together for the
first time with your team
you gotta sort of plan the upcoming
months and and and make a grand plan and
and then but what are you gonna do how
are you gonna how do you actually
prepare for a world championship
yeah we we had a team formed for the
candidates
um that was rooster
um
christian lanier
and alejandro it was he wasn't uh really
part of the training camp for the
candidates but then he came worked for a
few days and
uh and came on board for the world
championship match so that was the team
it was already already set in place
which was nice um there wasn't much
thought that had to be given for that
um
we just had to figure out the time
periods
we managed to schedule about
three months um
maybe a bit more maybe it was a bit less
but about three months of training
which uh with a lot of people is a lot
of time to do
to do significant work and meaningful
work
but
chess is also such a vast game that
um
you can go on and on forever without
feeling that you you know checked
everything that you wanted to
and especially because it's not only
important to do the work but also to
assimilate it
and everyone can do work but i'm the one
who has to actually i mean that that
task is is for me alone because i have
to make sure that i understand the
positions and i'm comfortable with them
um i'm i'm the only one who's going to
be playing them so
um but you're saying you have a team
there's like four to five people
is
everyone getting a certain task and that
it doesn't mean
that what one gm is is going to look at
certain range of openings and the other
one is looking at other openings or is
it completely different
uh that's usually the case of course it
it's very flexible um
but
we usually would uh
give certain positions or certain
openings to
uh to different people so that would be
their area and i would let's say play
training games against them
um or check their analysis every now and
then to see if it it suits me
um
of course things change a lot some you
know things not everything is uh always
organized and sometimes there's some
uh there's some switching around or
people
uh people move or i move from one
opening to another or um
or you know sometimes plans change
entirely because you check an opening
and you're excited about it uh it looks
good but then you find a problem and you
might have to
scrap the work at what stage
do you make
like big decisions for example in this
match you decided that if he goes for
the spashnikov well i'll first try try
to punch him a few times with the
russell limo and then at some point i
might i will also switch to the to the
actual uh swashnikov
at what stage of this preparation are
you actually choosing those kind of
choices
well i think we made the biggest
decisions in the first camp
um that was the decision to play e4
mostly
how long ago before the match is that
how much time before the match was that
i don't remember the exact dates i i
remember it was in the summer i don't
remember if it was june or july
um
yeah it's it's all the exact time frame
is a bit foggy my memory
but it was
i believe after
after norway
that's that's okay
so yeah we made the the biggest
decisions there i mean the decision to
play e4
not to focus on um
on d4 because it felt like it would be
too much
because magnus has a very wide
repertoire and so i would have to have a
pretty much a complete d4 repertoire to
challenge him there
so it felt like it would be too too much
work to
to go for so that was and the other
decision was what to play with black
in terms of what to play in e4 and the
petrol uh sticking with it was was
decided and the queen's gambit declined
um
overall i felt like
we both uh did very well with black
somehow our black preparation worked out
uh
very well and our white preparation
not so much uh that was my feeling of
course it's
um
like we we did still challenge each
other at times but but that was my
general impression are you actually
uh looking at
everything i mean
you you of course you focus on the main
openings that magnus always plays
but of course there's always an option
that he will play something that he has
never played before uh it could even
could even be the ajejin or or
the friend yeah the french that he
doesn't play too often to what extent
are you actually also checking your
lines in in all the other openings
yeah we um no that was that was
something i assumed that he could very
easily jump because at the time he was
playing the marshall mainly so a lot of
effort work was put into the marshall um
[Music]
but
i think there was a general assumption
that
it's at least a 50 chance that he's
playing another opening
um and one of
like let's say the big ones are the
marshall the berlin let's say these are
the safety nets the places where
someone can prepare and feel very
comfortable with their preparation
um
and the night earth uh
and the swastika was not quite as on uh
on our radar as other openings so that's
why um
the ros limo was our
uh
was our main choice we didn't actually
get to work on this 95 question called
until during the match
uh that was all all on the spot um the
roast limo was where i felt
most comfortable and i thought that's
where i'll challenge him in case he goes
here
uh but the preparation just wasn't good
we hadn't put enough time into it uh or
enough care and
and it
really
like it didn't work out too well um
the swatching called 95 worked out
far better there i posed significant
problems
for him
um but that was that was all the work
that uh my team i i wasn't even mostly
involved with my team was doing during
the match i was checking in and trying
to remember
desperately trying to remember and
figure out the positions
um but that was gonna get back to that
[Music]
i'm going to get back to the memory game
also later on but
um
as you're saying you even if there's
three
three to five months
you cannot
prepare for for everything it's just
it's just the chess game is too big it's
just too much but still
if you look back
uh
at the preparation period uh was is
there anything you would do differently
now
after you have played matching you know
what everything that happened and is
there anything you would have changed if
you could
in preparation preparation wise
yeah in terms of approach i think we did
things pretty well especially
considering
um
it was my first time preparing for this
level of event rustom had experience um
he had he had prepared world
championship matches before with vishy
uh he had worked uh
for years and years with bishi so he
knew the the terrain well
but for the rest of us this was
completely a new terrain
uh so i think that our approach was was
pretty good um there were of course
mistakes analytical mistakes mistakes in
terms of uh where we put our
um
our emphasis in the openings
but i i think i was
like besides opening work which is of
course a very big part of it
um
i think i was in very good chest shape
that year also during the match i think
the
the level was generally high it was a
high quality
um for the classical portion until until
we got to rapid
uh and my play throughout that year was
quite good and i think that's also in
part because
i was working on chess diligently and
practicing a lot not only openings but
also
general chess skills and tools um
so
and and we did as much work we put as
much time in this as we could i
i was working more than i i had
at any period in my chest career so
there was never there was not really a
moment during the match that you were
like oh
my gosh why didn't we look at this or
how could we forget or
how why on earth was this not done
oh like specific openings for sure but i
i think that only comes with hindsight
so you can't
like of course i can say
we should have checked the
brush the this question called rosely
rosalino
complex more
we should have put more
uh emphasis there we also
had for example
in the petrol of a glaring error that
was dead lost like i i was actually my
main line was
was losing life force so so there were
things like that but when did you notice
that
well the thing is like it was it was one
point
where
we just needed to be a bit more diligent
with the computer the computer was um
i think it's like but i actually
discovered this during the match or or
during the prep it was discovered after
i was preparing for aftermath
and
checked the line and i
and not like i'm not exaggerating when i
say lost
the the position was actually
forced made more or less it was so you i
guess it would be complicated
it's possible you could have lost the
game in the match like that
it it was possible it's a very narrow
point he would have to
to stumble on it but
it was kind of comparable to um
kramnik's
mistake in preparation against uh
against leicester international
um so yeah these things happen
um
one of the things is that
like i can only say this with hindsight
but the the evolution of chess
uh engines mostly software hardware i
mean the
computers have also gotten stronger but
um but the whole
evolution that started with alpha zero
and with neural nets um
[Music]
really like the level of chess engines
improved so
um
so much more than it has in any other
time period that i've that i've been
working on chess
so
now that mistake would never happen
uh three years later like that
analytical mistake computers were just
spotted instantly
but back then
by the way
is this what
this is what you could say do i
understand correctly that maybe three
years ago you were you were still
running engines locally and now with
cloud engines it's a different story no
we we used cloud engines and we used um
okay
so we were actually working with a
company that was that was providing us
um very very powerful hardware but the
computers were different like we nobody
was really using view of them so we
started using lila um
and and i i don't think that i mean i
assume magnus was also um
using lila at the time but it was still
a very rare thing lilo was was extremely
weak then compared to now
um
[Music]
it was it would very often
blunder mates
or not be able to win end games a rook
up you know things like that it had some
some weird glitches but it was also
helpful in preparation but just now
everything is
has improved um astronomically i mean
like the rate of improvement is
amazing
right yeah
and of course
what it also means is that
the the level of preparation will be
extremely high and but
not if you all both have an extremely
high level preparation and also maybe in
a lot of variations
uh
i guess that's you can say that for top
level just these days in general that
uh
all of you have have also maybe a very
similar analysis
prepared in a lot of lines because
you're going to reach the same
conclusions if you're if you're using
the same strong engines i guess and of
course you have to use your your own uh
human
touch and your style and your preference
uh
for for
actually making the moves that you like
to make on the board but
uh as i see i see it is there's going to
be a huge amount of information and a
number of moves
both of you will be producing uh
[Music]
so my other question about this is how
on earth are you going to remember all
that how do you
memorize
all those lines
for for tournament games and and for
world championship match what do you do
to look at all this information in your
head and and use it
yeah the memorization thing is
is a big question um
like let's say there are players with
better memories and worst memories but
even magnus who probably has the best
memory among chess players
uh or among top chess players
well still struggles uh and um
and i think that has also changed
approach because you don't want to
to be cramming lines into your head
before every game it's just it's
exhausting it might work for a single
game but overall it's an exhausting
thing
although that is an approach that some
players take
that's why people
now look for small directions
which might not be
you know
might not lead to an advantage very
likely won't
um
but they're hoping that their opponent
might not be so familiar with it uh and
and if it has a safety net then that's
already considered a very
a very decent idea you know something
where you can test your opponent a bit
um hopefully you get a game
uh if you don't and the safety net it
means that there's always a possibility
that you draw the game or
yeah that you don't take excessive risks
that you always have the situation under
control at least um and i think most
players are adopting this
um especially in the
age of online rapid chess and well rapid
chance in general
where
um
you know if you have a try
uh something which will
put some pressure on your opponent and
exclude the possibility of you losing
you know you might win one every three
games and this is already
a great success
uh so it's it's a much more practical
approach now
um but for a world championship match i
guess players are
are still going to go for some sort of
complete preparation
where they try to
have everything figured out
with black at least um so that they
try not to experience any surprises with
black and would white try to put
pressure here and there and
and you know you don't have to
you don't have to win
all the games you just have to win one
um that that's enough to put in the lead
so so the idea isn't to wipe your point
off the board idea is just to maximize
your equity
right but
and more from the practical sense
is there a certain way you use to
actually
uh study your lines i mean
is there like a these days a lot of
people talk about uh repeated repetition
uh
language learning for example
uh all kinds of there are all kinds of
memory tricks uh to have hooks uh
certain lines and moves need to be uh
you have to have a connotation maybe uh
certain uh maybe older games or
there's all kinds of ways in which you
can actually memorize things is there
something you would do or is there
something that you know that top-level
craftmasters are using to
to memorize things
uh i don't i don't know about everyone i
think that for me and probably this is
similar for a lot of players
uh
positions that you see over the board
and that you play with
and not just uh you know scroll through
lines on a computer that was sick in
your head the best and for the longest
period of time
um if you just want to cram before a
game then just going through all the
moves on a computer before game will
probably
uh probably suffice but it also
uh from my experience exits your memory
very quickly uh so you know three days
later you might not remember a thing of
what you what you've seen
um
[Music]
a lot of players have repertoires where
they
constantly revisit the same openings and
lines
and see the same positions
you know
let's say 10 times during a tournament
uh they've seen the same positions
hundreds of times so of course that
really sticks in your memory at some
point
if you see a player like
well let's say maxine is a good example
who places lines
um
almost religiously you know he he sticks
to his guns
um
he's he's seen the same position so many
times that he will stick in his memory
but still you you make mistakes i mean
memory isn't isn't perfect
it can fade um
and and we're only human so
so there's always but there's always
bound to be some mistakes um
but i think what
players who or people who aren't so
familiar with
um
you know preparing for games or who
haven't seen the
uh
[Music]
the routines that players go to go
through before games
uh they assume that's all memorization
but very often at the board it's a lot
of
trying to
calculate lines
to kind of jog your memory um
trying to work through all the details
so a lot of times like
i i see a position at the board and i
know that i've seen this before
but i don't remember the details so i'm
calculating and
trying to to work through everything to
to regain that familiarity and it comes
back once you start thinking and
calculating
um
[Music]
but it's not just you know players
repeating moves that they
analyzed beforehand without any thought
it's it's very often thinking about why
are we making these moves and
um
what happens at this what happens with
that
um one of the things is that
you can't
you can't analyze everything it's too
much of a jungle
so very often at the board you might
come across a move which is sensible
uh it looks sensible but you know that
it wasn't something that
was in the notes or the computer showed
and then you try to figure out
based on your knowledge that this move
might not be so good
try to figure out why so there's there's
a lot of things like that
moving away from from preparation and
openings a little bit uh and more about
the actual the actual part of playing
playing games in a world championship
an important question i think is what
what for you is
is the most challenging part of playing
a world championship match
um well everything is challenging
uh
one of the things is that it's it's this
is to some extent true in most ornaments
that it's non-stop chess
that you go from thinking about the game
to playing the game to thinking about
the next game
uh but in the world championship it's
far more intense because you
can't really afford to make a mistake or
let your guard down
so that builds up the pressure
it's it really
i mean at some point it takes its toll
you know
it's not only a mental toll but also a
physical toll um
[Music]
so yeah in general the pressure probably
and the stress of the match
is the most difficult part um
i mean the fact that you're playing
you know a player like magnus you know
uh
one of the greatest players in the
history of chess
uh and you know that
he won't make a single moment
of any game easy for you
uh so you'll
you'll always have to to work for
everything whether it's
if you're trying to win a game or if
you're trying to defend a
worse position
um you know that every moment will be
difficult
um so so it it's it's overall very
challenging thing
is that
by the way
uh
kind of unique
for magnus
is he
the only player
you face or you have faced as you say
that that makes every single moment in a
game difficult
well there's
i mean he's he's the player who's
uh
i mean overall the strongest the most
accurate and most consistent
um he also puts pressure on you in a way
that some players sometimes let up on
the pressure
magnus usually doesn't ever let up
he almost always
keeps it up whether it's in terms of
defense because sometimes he'll get a
bad position but he he's a very good
defender and also in terms of
um
[Music]
like there's a moment in games when it
feels like it's heading towards a draw
and a lot of players just sort of coast
um
and once you've played a lot with magnus
you understand that he never coasts so
if you make a slight inaccuracy it can
turn into a slightly unpleasant position
and sometimes i can snowball into
turning a
a game that
feels like it's about to be drawn into a
game that
that you might lose
um
[Music]
that was actually one of the things i
was proud of in the match that in those
like let's say
six hour moments in the game i i was
actually
um
i think uh playing better than him in
those
long end games that we played and we
played
quite a number of them
um that was actually one of my strengths
during the match
it was still only a minor strength
because we did end up trying all the
games
but uh it was uh at least something that
i was very that i was looking out for
not to relax at any moment um
but there like if you take any top
player or most top players
they they always put pressure on you
they always make life difficult like
when i'm playing like shock vr or level
i understand that this is going to be a
really tough game
uh and i'm going to have to solve a lot
of problems but i also know that um they
can make
extremely serious mistakes
um
[Music]
at any moment and magnus is
he can make those mistakes but he's a
bit less likely to um so that's that's
sort of the feeling i got
one of those examples of uh
of long games where you where you were
doing well uh well at least you you held
on was that first game you already
described it you you actually held a
very difficult uh lost end game
apparently
um
did that
yeah you said this this was actually
perhaps one of the key moments of the
whole match maybe it could have gone
very differently so that brings me to
the question how how big
does psychology play a role in a world
championship and is it is it more is it
an even bigger role than in other
tournaments
um
i i don't know if it's bigger than other
tournaments the only thing is that in
other tournaments
if you don't get first place you don't
uh beat yourself up over it
um so it's really that the stakes are
higher but if we started to analyze
why every player didn't win you know
norway chess or sink field cup or
or tied a steel
then
then we'd understand that a lot of it is
definitely due to psychology a lot of
players just lose interest in a
tournament
uh when it's not going their way or
um
[Music]
you know uh
are
not defending um
[Music]
tenaciously enough when they're getting
bad positions like for sure these things
uh factor in uh into into every chess
game into every tournament
probably at almost every level not just
at the top level
um it's just that when it's a world
championship match and
suddenly we're analyzing uh both players
um
in terms of their psycho psychological
approach and preparation approach and
and every aspect of how they're
going into the game uh but we don't put
that same
uh we don't give the same spotlight to
to the 10 players that are playing
um
yeah let's say the same field cup
uh but i think the psychology is very
very similar in most ways
and do you have to keep telling yourself
uh
not to
we
i mean emotions creep in you have games
where you you survive lost positions you
also had your games where you missed
your chances and
to what extent are you telling yourself
uh
not to do all about it focus on the next
game and that kind of stuff is that
important or
actually do you actually
go through games
well uh
deeply uh to deal with them to get them
behind you how do you deal with moving
from one game to the next game
yeah well i had the two moments that
were disappointing during the match
uh in terms of moments during that i
could have won games
one was the uh end game where i was
objectively winning
yeah there was this cessna norway uh
super computer show sort of showing but
several grandmasters
saw the waiting line and still couldn't
understand it so yeah i was actually
curious did you to what extent did you
actually try to understand that winning
line and how did you feel about that
well i like i
at first i
thought
this isn't very logical i i don't really
understand why this is winning
uh then when i thought about it more in
terms of white's options
um
it became clear that if i made this move
even if i just made it randomly because
at that point i was
like
i've been putting pressure on him for
most of the game
at some point for most of the end game
but at some point
i just thought okay it's going to be a
draw because i i didn't see a way
forward um and then we started moving
around moving around and he he made his
move
which allowed me to win
um but during the game it felt just like
like the last 15 moves and the next 10
moves it didn't feel like he made a
mistake because nobody told me
well
you're winning at exactly this moment
so i didn't really pay much attention to
it during the game
um after the game it was press
conference and this was also i think the
game
where there was that whole uh thing with
the
um
with the video i think it was after that
game
but i'm not
maybe i wasn't that was during game four
actually
yeah was it
yeah i probably yeah it's also a bit of
hazing my memory um
[Music]
but yeah it's
then i started to think i was like
playing through it in my head and i
realized that
that white's options are very limited
after this movement and it is actually
once you make it it's a pretty
straightforward win
um
so you could actually figure it out
blindfully
how it works
i think um if someone told me this is
winning
then i no i'm just saying after the game
you you didn't get you didn't put it on
a chess set in your hotel room and then
and actually
you actually saw it in your head
yeah there was still the next game to
focus on and um
yeah but that's also my question to what
extent to what extent do you actually go
deep into that or or you're just like
whatever i'm going to focus on tomorrow
well we we don't look at the games i i
don't look at the game at all but you do
think about the game that's it it stays
in your head and you can't
um
if you miss a very clear win then it
might keep you up all night um
[Music]
if
uh
if it's something like that which is
very difficult and which was a bit
random bit of a random chance that i got
in a drawn position just because he made
a careless move that neither was
realized
uh it didn't hit me too hard
the the one which really um
really disappointed me was when i played
this move h3
yeah
um
he was much lower on time and i had an
objectively
much better to to maybe even winning
position
uh and i just
i was kind of trying to press him on
time i was trying to keep pressure up
and then i i made this positional move
which uh
which wastes an important tempo
uh it was it was a stupid moment because
that was fully in my control i could
have just sat there
been disciplined and
tried to figure out the position better
so yeah those are the two moments i
think when i had chances to to win a
game
but that second example is was that
something that was lingering for more
than just a day in your head or your
head or
could you cope with it easily or
well it definitely lingered for more
than a day the question is to linger for
for more than a year
oh that was disappointing it's not like
it's not like that's the end of the
match if i win that game
um
but it's i would have uh
you know
uh he would have been in a very very
difficult position
um
so so yeah and it was also
it's not really
like sometimes you have a win that's an
objective win like just mathematically
winning like that end game but you don't
feel so bad about it because you feel
like
it's somewhat
uh it's somewhat above you you know like
you can't figure out everything over the
board and there's some things which
aren't even objectively like it's not
the end of the game if i don't play h3
but
but at least i shouldn't do that
and it was something you could have
found
it's not even finding it it's like it's
it's not even a chess mistake really
it's it's just
uh impulsiveness and
and carelessness uh and all these
um non-chest things that made me rush
and
uh
or
you know i like the
of course you see the different moves
and and you can figure them out so this
this was not really a chess mistake
um while the other one was a chess
mistake but one which i i think i can
forgive myself for
that being said he he also missed uh
a far easier and clearer win in the
first game so it's not like i was the
only one who
uh who had regrets during the classical
segment
it's uh i don't want to give the answer
in your mouth but one of the questions
is also what
what would be the biggest lesson
you got from this match i i can imagine
that one of the things is that you would
tell yourself i need i should shouldn't
be
impulsive in any game in any moment but
is there anything bigger
from in terms of of what you learned
from playing magnus for 12 games in a
positive playoff
well i definitely learned a lot about
chess and
a lot about how to approach chess
a lot about how i play
uh
how i approach the game and the mistakes
i make the weaknesses i have
um
[Music]
like in term is that based on like a
thorough analysis of your games
afterwards was there actually a moment
where you
with maybe with your seconds you
actually went through all the games uh
very deeply and then and tried to learn
from that or
no i never
i never looked at the games again
after
i never
um
i mean it is of course a painful thing
uh
uh to feel like you're close and then to
to miss out on it
um
so i didn't think about the games i
never like
actually check them either on a computer
or on a board afterwards it's supposed
to be good for your chest to analyze
your game you know
yeah that's uh that's totally true
um
it is interesting
i'm not sure i took the right lessons
away from that um
uh
of course it was a very strange
three years that proceeded uh that uh
that followed it
um true yeah no but it doesn't make me
wonder because you said you learned so
much uh
so
so it's it's kind of curious that
yeah
how did you get all those insights so
just purely from from from
from playing the games and and all the
memories you have from from from the
moves that he played or how does how did
it work in your case then
well it wasn't so much the moves it was
more
how i i think about chess in general and
how i how i make
decisions uh and that's not always just
about
you know analyzing a move and figuring
out the truth of the physician that's
more about thinking about what's what's
in my head
um and one of the things i realized that
magnus
um
at some point thought about me
uh in a way that he figured out my
strengths and weaknesses
um and i never really
felt that before with another player
that they were actually sitting down and
trying to figure out what i'm good at
and trying to aim for those positions um
but i realized that magnus just did that
diligently and understood me
um probably pretty well as a player
uh and i don't think that i quite um did
the same for him or at least not as well
i probably wasn't as diligent in my
approach towards the player rather than
just
let's say not towards my chest but
towards his chest because
in a tournament that doesn't matter like
i'm playing nine other people or four uh
or in the candidate seven other people
um
[Music]
and i i can't think about the
you know psychoanalyze every single
player i i just need to make sure that
my chest is as good as it can can be but
when it's one on one then you then that
really um
has a lot of importance
so he he did that better than me
uh
that that's for sure i think that's
probably also one of his strengths
um the psychological part and
um
[Music]
and being able to understand what to do
against specific people
uh
so yeah that's that's probably
i like let's say the
what i did before the match was probably
good but what i did after the match
um
probably wasn't i probably could have
done better in terms of
um
[Music]
in terms of how i approach chess
it kind of felt like uh once the match
was over and i just needed to release
tension
and
and that led to me not being very
serious for
uh for you know a solid year or so
um and then after that
pretty much that was the point when uh
when covet happened and
and chess got very strange
yeah yeah
yeah going a little bit back to what you
actually just gave i actually
remember that in one of the press
conferences during the match you said
that you
you did see flaws in magnus's game
during your preparation but but you
couldn't find a pattern
uh
and now looking back after the match or
or just nowadays
do you
have a more clear vision yourself what
max's weaknesses would be
and what young should be focusing on
um it's actually difficult uh with
magnus says
with the mistakes he makes
because i i look at his games and i
uh of course i see that he makes
mistakes and every everyone does and
that's that's normal uh nobody is immune
from that
but
they
they don't seem to have a very clear
pattern
um
and i don't know if that's because of
his universality or because i'm
just not very good at
figuring things out
um but it might be because uh he is
generally good in
in pretty much all areas
um and the mistakes he makes are not
because
uh you know you can just target him like
you have to play this type of position
and that he's going to
he's not going to play as well as you
um
[Music]
like we we kind of understand at least
or i think that's that was a feeling
that we understand remind us the
strengths are so we consider things that
aren't his strengths his weaknesses
um but that's that's more of like a
relative weakness than
uh he's not good at that type of
position
um but you know with minus overall he is
uh
he is extremely universal he he does
figure things out pretty well in most
positions that you'll give them
yeah by the way before i forget uh we
might have to
use this somewhere else in the interview
um but uh you did mention that uh
well it was actually in the morning of
game four uh that there was a
video posted online pretty today in
chess program produced by the saints
with chess club
it was uh showing you uh
uh at their uh at the wrecks in genesee
fields farm estate at the osage river
uh you you you were in the video doing
all kinds of uh relaxing things and and
of course there was a famous shot of the
laptop and uh lines of opening
opening variations were shown it was a
bit of a big thing
on that day especially in the next day
during the match
your team
didn't really want to comment on it the
video was actually removed for online
very soon
uh
maybe
now or now three years later can you say
a little bit more about
what happened and to what extent this
actually influenced influenced your prep
or your play
yeah so so we were working at the forum
that was our first training session uh
we called the farm but it's
basically uh rex and jeannie's
summer house it's a very large place and
it has a lot of sports amenities and
uh it was it was pretty ideal for
for us to have a training session and um
one of the ideas was that the production
crew
will come in a day
they'll basically film us
playing blitz or solving studies or
whatever
um
and then we'll like play some sports and
and they'll be released at some
undisclosed time after the match
um that was the idea
after me
like we they came we didn't we weren't
even like really working on chess today
that was just considered a day that
we'll you know we'll do some stuff for
the camera um
not stuff that we would normally
work on
um
and then we went to play basketball and
tennis with them and they filmed some of
that too
and uh and that was it and i didn't
really think about it until um
until after the game
and
like christian comes to me after the
game and he seems
concerned about something at first i i
wasn't i didn't understand what it was
and then he said like
the analysis was leaked something like
that
um and yeah the
what he
what they said was that they they had
known the entire day
um
but
but they didn't want to tell me before
the game so
so they just waited until after the game
and they told me them so that i wouldn't
seem completely
oblivious during uh
during the press conferences press
conference when it inevitably came up
and basically i just said uh you know
some
i won't comment some stuff like that i
don't even remember clearly what i said
um
[Music]
but that was that was pretty much it it
didn't actually affect
my preparation like the decision was
made
because there was this file that
basically said that i
that said knight f6
like knight g7 i have six in the petrol
so it's very clear what the lot what the
file name means what line it's saying
um
but it doesn't mean that i'm going to
play this line it just means that at
some point i checked this
you know um
in the past you know year at some you
know like it wasn't it didn't give an
enormous amount of information i felt so
the decision was just not to
change the prep in any way
i ended up playing this line
in the
in the penultimate game
where magnus didn't really put much
pressure on me and he went for the end
game and it was
a relatively uh uneventful draw
uh and i guess people felt like maybe
because of that sequence of events
that it was almost some sort of
bizarre uh
psychological ploy but it definitely
wasn't i
i i
i don't try to to do things like that
and i'm also not sure
it would even be a good idea like maybe
it didn't have a negative effect this
time but not sure it would be a good
idea overall
um
but yeah it's it also felt a bit like
the controversy was a bit overblown
because
i don't think it really affected the
games in the match very much um
maybe magnus didn't expect me to play
this line because it was shown on the
computer but this
would have just been a happy coincidence
if that's the case
and i also don't know
how it affected him in terms of
what they did with this information if
anything
um uh it was
yeah that was all
that's all it really was
yeah yeah i got it
all right let's move to uh to the
upcoming match um
yeah
how do you see it i mean
the the the cliche questions i need to
ask as well uh to what extent
is magnus still the favorite by what
margin how do you look at it
um
it's actually a strange time to ask that
question because
like i haven't seen magnus play
classical chess
or over the board chess and forever i
mean well we played norway but that was
already a year ago maybe we do we have
to do one more recording session uh uh
after norwich yeah yeah
that's true maybe that will give us some
insight um
but we're in this strange situation
where a lot of players have mostly been
playing online chess for the past
uh year and a half have been more
um
[Music]
and magnus in his last classical event
in
uh like say
wasn't too impressive uh
he has been impressive in in online
chess overall um
he's won
i don't know most of the events he's
played but he's won a significant amount
of events he's played which is a very
impressive task
um
but
that's it's it's very different i mean
it's hard to say i don't think that you
know he's a different player or a weaker
player but we haven't
really seen much of him in action over
the board
so so that's something i think to
consider well
um jan has uh
like he's he's an enormously talented
player but one of his weaknesses was
always that he probably didn't take
chess
super seriously
uh he enjoyed other things and
uh and his approach to chess was maybe
not as serious as some of his uh
colleagues
um and i think that definitely changed
this year like after you're after you
qualify for the match you want to put
all your effort into it
um
so and i think he's probably doing that
uh i mean from the brief that bits i've
heard of his preparation he's taking it
very seriously and that would make
perfect sense
um
the thing is of course magnus is is
overall a better player
um that that is undoubtedly true
is he also not clearly better
against this particular opponent because
of course we all know that he actually
no problem she actually has a plus score
uh or is that just a
statistic and uh and not a another big
deal
i think jan was 5-0 against him and and
then he beat him
in um
one of the grandchild's two events i
think it was in
sagra maybe
um
but i don't think that's relevant at all
because a lot of those games were
even when they were kids or when they
were much younger
um
and i think the last time that young
beat him was in
london 2017
um
where we we tied for first um in the
grand chess tour of the last event there
and he beat magnus with black
he was under some slight pressure it was
an isolated composition but then he
he eventually beat him and of course
there's always once your five always
magnus which is an extraordinary thing
there's a lot of talk about you know
um
having a nemesis or you know having
someone who
uh who's just stylistically difficult
um but i think when we're talking about
a small sample size
and
they haven't played like what however
many games they played it's a relatively
small sample size
then
it's not super relevant you know if they
played a thousand games
uh then i would say okay this is
statistically very relevant but if they
played like 20 or 15 classical games and
okay this is
um this is relatively small and there's
going to be an element of randomness
there
so i don't put much weight into the
head-to-head result um
i basically like that that for me is
just a watch
like
if
if yon is a difficult opponent for him
um
[Music]
it's because uh
he's one of those players who can
um
he's a bit mercurial he can
play at a super high level or or let's
say he has maybe a wider um
uh
sort of level difference in his play
compared to other players so he can
he can play extremely well in it and if
he comes to the match at his very best
then um
then maybe he can play better than
magnus um it's possible that he can
outperform him
so
uh so that's one thing uh of course it's
also possible that you know i'm might
just have a bad match and not much of a
fight
um that can happen
do you think we will actually see it
within the match that young might
actually be showing those different
levels of play in in this one match
but i actually expected that during the
candidates um
because he was playing very well but i
thought that the second half he would
struggle a bit
but he didn't uh not at all
uh so
it felt like he gained some stability to
his play
which he had lacked in the past because
i remembered when
uh very often he would have
be having a great tournament and then
things would fall apart that happened at
several events in 2019 like instagram he
was plus three and he ended up 50 and
same field cup as well
and he had some games that were
like he would go from
amazing games
to just like he he loses to maxime
because of a blunder on like
pretty much move 10 without even
spending a single moment on the clock so
he he i think he solved those issues
which were plaguing him uh the
the sort of wild swings
uh he's probably
still a bit of a streaky player
but he i don't think that he's going to
come and
uh
and you know lose a game because he's
rushing or
that seems to be an issue in the past
for him uh he he was he was very
impressive in uh in paris in the rapid
event he felt like the rapping
blitzerman it felt like he um he's just
overall
confident and
um
full of ideas and uh
and that's probably uh
a result also of him working a lot i
guess usually when someone's working a
lot and
and um
[Music]
uh
and sort of you know into chess like on
a daily daily level then you feel that
in their in their play so that's that's
what i felt when he was playing in paris
uh which is a very good sign for him of
course
he still
every now and then plays as you
mentioned games where he
just doesn't think that much he's he's
playing his moves really fast and
has a lot of time on the clock by the
time the game ends
do you think it can make a difference
that he is he might actually be able to
pressure magnus on the clock
i don't think so
um i don't feel like that's his strength
actually because uh
he
he does have these amazing games
sometimes where he beats a top player
without spending a single moment on the
clock and this is this is an amazing
achievement
um
but i don't see that ever happening to
magnus that he's going to beat him
without putting the effort in
and i think it's more likely to backfire
if you try something like that
um
and when he played
in uh
during the candidates he kept he kept up
a good pace like he wasn't really
getting to
serious time pressure that's uh that's
obviously not a problem for him
uh but he wasn't rushing he wasn't
ending games you know with now on his
clock he was playing at a at a healthy
pace which is a good thing and i think
that's probably the approach he's going
to take during the match
yeah and as you mentioned your spell
yourself
uh
part of his
good score uh against magnus might also
have to do with his
uh style of play uh
do you think that is a
that is actually something that
madness is
sort of struggling with the way
young plays and if so
can you sort of describe what what makes
jan's style what what is his style and
and why is it
different from other top players
uh well
it's not not so different i would say i
mean
like the differences between top players
are going to be in the details
um but let's say ian has
uh
an aggressive intuitive style so he he
has a good feeling for chess especially
when he plays with the initiative and he
likes to put pressure on his opponents
um and he he's an excellent calculator
so that fits in well with that
but that's also
i think a typical style that you'll find
with uh with other people i mean of
course there's there's
there's always going to be differences
in how people and how players approach
games and different rules and different
types of positions but that's also how i
would describe for example
um
you know how leveling plays in some way
like that sort of
um positional good positional feeling
for especially for the initiative or how
to paul place i was that was always one
of his um
his strengths
um
[Music]
but yeah it's like that doesn't say so
much about
beyond the player i'd say just saying
that he's
an aggressive positional player you know
um
[Music]
he's also one player that i haven't had
as much experience as others as against
others
um
maybe because he
he only reached the let's say the
pinnacle of chess in the last
um
few years like
i remember he won uh he was we were tied
first in london in 2017 in the
tournament where he beat magnus
uh
and he had an excellent tournament and
so did i it was it was one of my best
events
and um but his reigning at the time was
only 27 30.
so it he he felt like an underdog coming
into the event and then he had a great
result and now of course he doesn't i
mean he's not an underdog at all he's
uh
he's
for sure one of the best players in the
world
but it's it's more of a recent thing i
guess it was because he solved some of
the issues that
that he was having
uh some of the
let's say
game breaking issues he was how he he
was overall very good then he had these
moments
that were just
taking away all his hard work during
games
um
so he solved that and then he just he
just uh shot up to
to 2800 um
pretty much so uh
but
in terms of how many games like i i
haven't played many games against him
which uh
which is how i would get a very good
feeling for how a player is by playing
them over and over
right well you have played magnus many
more times and
including a match um
i don't know if he did but
what if what if john would would would
hire you or just
ask you for for a phone call
and and he wanted your advice what what
advice would you give jan
to beat madness in this match
well i don't know if my advice would be
any different than what his coaches are
like i feel like he's probably
surrounded by good people who know chess
and who know how to approach as well
uh but i don't have like some
secret insight into you know how to how
to beat magnus um
or maybe the other way around so
what shouldn't he do
well i mean he's uh he's going to have
to take this very seriously and realize
that
um
[Music]
like
once he gets there this is going to be
he's going to have to
to
endure the enormous pressure
and not let up for one second for
for the entirety uh for the duration of
the match and he can't relax basically
at all like you even if he's up in the
match
um
he can't ever get the thought that
i'm going to to win this until it's
actually over
um because
it's definitely going to be
an enormously difficult match for both
of them and
it's not going to be
the pressure won't let up until until
the last minute
um
and then of course the
a lot of
what happens during the match is decided
now and over the past few months
and
over the period until a match
uh
how they get in shape
mental shape physical shape chest shape
and how they're able to play as well as
they can
and
hopefully he feels comfortable with his
team as well um
i don't know who he's working with but
uh
but it's very important to have people
around you who you trust and who you
enjoy being with so
uh if he has a good setup uh
if he's prepared well
then he he has a shot um
but it there's no like secret you know
secret cure or anything like you just
have to to prepare well and play as well
as you can and
um
and be ready to uh to endure the
pressure in this recipe
right yeah by the way
uh maybe related to the earlier
discussion about uh the strong engine
preparation and all that i was also
wondering how you see this uh how likely
is it that we're going to be seeing 14
draws this time
i don't think uh we'll see all draws i
also wouldn't have counted on it last
time it just uh
just happened like it was 14 euros but
it could have also been
first game decisive and then who knows
what happens right like i could have
lost the first game if magnus had made
one move differently and then who knows
what the match could have been for
decisive games or
like it's it's uh it's really impossible
to say
uh so i i definitely wouldn't count on
ultras um
this time
i i don't think that it's going to have
the like it's not going to be up and
down the entire time it's probably still
going to have a high percentage of draws
um
because most world championship matches
do
if we go back to
um like
character against magnus was okay they
both won a game of peace
um
[Music]
and uh
trying to remember bishop against magnus
it was also it was three decisive games
was in 2014.
um so it's not like there's a it's not
like every game is going to be decisive
you know just just because
uh they're both fighting players you
could still see
a lot of draws
but okay in whatever way they reach it
they might actually
reach a 7-7 score on the scoreboard uh
i you already said that in in classical
magnets should definitely still be
considered
at least a slight favorite but how about
the playoff how do you see
things in terms of favorite uh when it's
actually coming down to red and blitz
i would still consider magnus a favor
but i think that he
would rather wrap the match up
in classical um
assuming he wraps it up as a win
not a loss
um
but yeah
it's
like it's just a general thing i i mean
i he he is i think stronger
um than jan and wrapped in blitz
but the
kind of i think the
because it's
it's less games and um
and more randomness i think that uh
that actually favors underdog
um
[Music]
and
like in wrapping blitz i really wouldn't
be comfortable
you know betting on a favorite let's say
i i would still say magnus should be
considered a favorite but it shouldn't
be a major
a major edge that he has well in
classical i think that um he still
should have a pretty good action i think
this is more or less all i wanted to ask
except that
uh there's one thing i don't know i
don't know to what extent you want to
talk about it it's fine if you don't but
it is something that also makes the
article
a little bit more topical
and that is uh i was wondering if you
could
give a comment on rustam's interview on
chess base
he i don't know if you have read it in
full or not but he basically uh
describes uh
or talks about the fact that you
discontinued
working together
and i think one of his quotes was that
the pandemic didn't do much good to the
relationship between you guys
so
yeah
do you want to say something about it uh
and if so please do
well i i don't think that um
[Music]
i don't know exactly um
like
when he said that i don't know if he
meant uh in terms of the chess
relationship because i think that
uh we're still on good terms
uh and that remained uh also actually
the pandemic
um but it's true that uh
definitely the last year and a half
wasn't
wasn't very good for our um
our trust chess relationship because
we didn't have much time to work and it
became very very difficult
to arrange things with traveling
um
it
i think it it really um
also hurt uh
brewstem's um
sort of uh
sword
um
his enthusiasm for the work that we were
doing
um it also hurt my enthusiasm for chess
i was
definitely not really into chess for a
period during during the last year and a
half but just it was very difficult for
me to get motivated and i think that was
also the same for him and then we had
is that also because you're maybe less
less into online chess than some of your
colleagues i get the feeling that you
maybe enjoy playing online not as much
as some of your your
peers i have i have no problem playing
online it's uh
i mean the online chess thing is
something i don't
think i should get fully into but uh
let's say i have security concerns
and that's one of my main concerns with
online chess
um
and that's one of the reasons why after
i i have what do you mean the security
concerns
what do you mean that
i like
i i just think that uh
and i think we've seen this and uh it's
sort of hit me
in some way after the uh protest lead
match uh last year that uh oh you mean
that's what online cheating is
is a serious attraction
oh sorry yeah gotcha
i know that uh some
websites uh
some platforms are
working really hard um
to to try solve this issue but it still
is
still an issue and uh
and a lot of players have no problem
playing
under those
under let's say the
uh
the shadow that it casts um but i played
very actively in online chess
for most of 2020
and then after that uh that thing with
uh
uh during the protest league
um
[Music]
it really like
it just made me
let's say overly maybe even overly
suspicious or maybe
adequately suspicious but in any case it
didn't it made me not enjoy all my chest
too much sure yeah
but but are you saying that
uh
as a result
there were simply not that many
tournaments to work on together with
ruston and therefore maybe it was
difficult to actually continue working
no we definitely could have um i mean
this was also uh
maybe even mostly my fault but at least
partly my fault
that um
that we weren't working enough um in
between in between events um
we also ran into a huge amount of
logistical difficulties
uh
which i i think is normal now you know
it's the state of the world
unfortunately it hits chess players
pretty hard
um
it's definitely it's also difficult to
you know
tell someone who has a family
to go to russia for a few days
go back and go to russia for a few days
for the same tournament a year later
or to quarantine for two weeks things
like that
um
[Music]
uh so i i fully understand why
uh his
enthusiasm for our work was uh it's not
at its highest and
and uh i felt the same about chess
overall for a period
um
but anyway uh
so here we so you were simply
also just
a bit less motivated to work on chess
for a while
yeah yeah yeah for sure um
yeah it definitely was
uh but our our
work ended amicably um
and there was no hard feelings on my
side and i hope none of this as well
um
when did you decide on this by the way
it was quite recent it was before the
last few tournaments
okay before uh
before the rapid uh blitz in san luis
okay but it was after the world cup
because he because he was not that he
was not with you at the world cup but he
wasn't at the world cup um that was
for a separate reason i i thought
that i would qualify by rating so i
didn't plan to play the world cup
uh and then they removed the rating
spots you know kind of suddenly
um
so i decided to play but uh
we had already i already told rustom
once ago make your plans and he had he
had his scheduled plans i think he was
playing uh
a tournament in dortmund
um
so okay that was uh it was just a last
minute
um last minute thing which uh
so he couldn't come to the tournament um
yeah
that's that was kind of unrelated to
us not working together anymore the very
last question is uh how are you going to
look for how are you looking forward to
with being a commentator
for
for a couple of weeks and and and yeah
change roles and and
how do you look forward to that
i like doing new things and uh and it's
definitely a new thing
i mean i've
i've spoken about chess you know i've
tried to explain my thoughts but i've
never done it
however many hours the games will go
straight you know could be could be four
hours could be seven hours uh
so it's going to be fun i'm also glad
that i'm doing it with people who i'm
uh friendly with and who i like and
enjoy their company um
so that's going to be nice
the time that i'll have to wake up not
not not what i'm looking forward to i'll
probably have to fly like two in the
morning
but uh i guess that's part of the job
uh but it will be really interesting
also to
to be really immersed
in a match the in 2016 i sort of
immersed myself in the
in the carlson kayaking match
um because i went to new york
uh
i didn't see i went to new york not for
the full event but for about half the
event i didn't see the players or visit
uh
let's say the spectator area but i
commented on the games
um
written comments uh analyzed the games
and
and i was there kind of almost in the
midst of it so so it'll be nice to
immerse myself
again in a world championship match
to really analyze the games deeply
and try to figure out along with the
rest of the world what
what the players are up to okay
well looking forward to that
[Music]
you